Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 2nd,
2018 what's going on?
How,
why?
Yeah.
A as you can tell.
Oh,
freckles is under the,
yeah,
I tried to do too much when I was on the road.
Uh,
I'm just an old guy enough and ended up catching a cold that goes to the middle
of fucking winter.
I flew into Minneapolis the day of the show.
I usually,
I used to fly in the night before,
but now I got the Kiddo and I don't,
uh,
you know,
misses a little bit of,
her whatever day as possible.
So I flew out the day of,
then I landed and um,
I've learned this lesson 50 fucking times and every time I've gotten sick I
landed.
I was a little tired,
you know,
cause I had to get up early to get there on time and I went right to the gym.
Stupid fucking move.
Then I had to do two shows and then I had hung out with Verdesian fucking
Barnick
but I slept in the next day and next day I woke up.
I kind of felt run down,
but I was like,
no man,
man,
I hit the gym again.
I hit the gym again,
fucking moron.
Then I take a steam,
then I go on fucking stage,
have one show,
CNN the night.
I absolutely love Barnet conversing a let's go out again.
So we go out again and this time we will,
we were at an outside bar up on this rooftop and this really cool,
you know,
place in,
downtown Minneapolis and a,
I had an add on,
but it wasn't enough.
And I could tell when I was,
you know,
when a cold just get you and I'm feeling a little bit and then it just get,
you're like,
ah,
fuck,
here we go.
And I didn't have any vitamins.
That's another thing.
I forgot my vitamins,
all of that dumb shit.
So,
um,
I dunno.
So I apologize for being so frigging late here,
but however I want to thank everybody.
It was one of the most fun weekends I've had as far as crowds.
And just what I got to see in Minneapolis,
in Detroit,
um,
Minneapolis,
first of all,
did the theater there on,
on the campus of,
uh,
the big 10 university of Minnesota.
Now,
I was joking with the people there whenever I go,
you know,
to a great campus like that.
My first thought,
this is for all you young kids out there.
I always think to myself,
man,
I wish I studied in high school.
I wish I tried.
This is fucking amazing.
Did we drove by there was like a frat house and there was like 10 frat guys
sitting in a circle playing some drinking games outside this amazing fraternity,
you know,
and I know everybody makes fun of them saying they're a bunch of date rapists
and then this and that and all this shit.
But at the end of the day,
who's making the robots that are going to kill all of us?
Huh?
It's the nerds.
So he's up on the Frat boys.
Um,
they're not all rapists,
you know,
some of them just lear.
So anyways,
and I couldn't believe fucking beautiful,
beautiful,
the University of Minnesota's campuses.
And I would say it on stage.
This is what a fucking moron am.
I,
you know,
without ever seeing a campus,
I judge what it looks like by how your sports teams are doing.
If you haven't won a big 10 championship or an SCC championship and a long time,
I just figured your schools a dump and it doesn't look good.
Am I learned that with Vanderbilt Vanderbilt's never like,
you know,
I think maybe in baseball they're good,
but they never do anything in football,
never do anything at home.
So I'm just like,
oh,
that's like almost a community college.
And then Nate board,
God's,
he told me it was a big fan of theirs was like,
no dude,
that's like,
it's one of the best schools in the country.
Some of the smartest things.
This engineering fucking eggheads school.
Right.
Um,
but I went into University of Minnesota.
It's like all fucking brick.
I mean,
what I saw of it was a,
was incredible.
Now I always have that thought,
like,
why didn't I study?
It wasn't that hard.
I was such a fucking pussy.
I was such a baby coupled [inaudible] who are two subject and just,
yeah,
they just get through it.
You know what I mean?
I didn't like doing hell rooms either,
but I,
I had to do them to get to do a fucking Gig at University of Minnesota.
I stuck with that.
Right.
Hang on.
Sorry.
I forget me.
It's going to be a lot of that.
I'll hit pause next time.
Um,
yeah,
look,
some of them math I get,
you know,
cause I gotta be honest with you.
Like I was cool right up until Algebra.
If I wasn't such a fucking class clown and a jerk off,
I wouldn't had to go to summer school after Algebra because it wasn't that bad.
If I applied myself geometry,
I don't even know what,
I don't,
I don't even know what the fuck was going on.
Was like these conspiracy theories about shapes,
not good spirit.
They have a proven,
um,
like the NBA is fixed,
was proven when they had that mobbed up ref.
And of course they blame it on one guy.
They always blame it on one guy.
I don't know how long people would sit there and watch the NBA.
I'm not saying all the Games of fixed,
I'm just saying no other sport is it finessed the way that sport is finesse to
make sure they have these match ups that are going to get ratings.
And it all goes back to fucking Larry Bird and magic Johnson.
I'm convinced of it and it's still fucking terrified because they almost went
out of business in the late seventies.
Um,
our ratings were way down,
you know,
but they all do it.
Like during the steroid era,
you think the fucking owners and baseball,
like they didn't know what the players were doing.
Baseball was in a bad way.
They canceled the world series.
Cal Ripkin breaking a Lou Gehrig's record was all they fucking had.
The chews up the ball.
They make the ballparks smaller.
These fucking guys are going up there looking like the dad and the Incredibles,
you know,
fucking skinny legs and Jane upper bodies just drive and shit over the f out of
the frigging Ballpark,
say,
knew what was going on.
And then all of a sudden the shit hits the fan and not one owner got asked a
question.
They,
oh,
I didn't know.
I had no idea.
You're in the business.
Right.
I do stand up comedy.
I know who some of the up and coming funny people are.
I hear who's stealing jokes.
I hear who's going to be the next fucking whatever I hear who is maybe a fucking
party in too much.
She a year,
you're in it,
you know,
it's what you do.
Fucking lumber jacks.
They know who's jerking off behind a redwood.
I mean they're in the fucking business.
So baseball was finessed that way,
I believe.
Right?
Football.
What they did was they just,
you know,
they weren't satisfied with their fan base and they just kept,
every fucking rule ended up being for the offense to the point.
It was borderline illegal to uh,
you know,
to fucking cover a receiver.
Now everybody's out there putting up Dan Marino numbers,
which is fucking ridiculous.
Dan Marino,
Dan filed those guys played back when you could borderline murder somebody,
stick them and all of that shit.
I remember one year that year drew Brees,
I can't forget what he threw four,
but it was just like,
there was like seven people on pace to break Dan Marino's record.
Maybe not seven.
It's probably four
in a,
in one season.
So it's finessed that fucking way,
right?
Hockey I,
it just,
I don't know what they're doing.
They just,
they,
they finally got it right.
They finally got it right with Nashville and Vegas and now they're going to
Seattle.
I think they're finally going to take a turn.
And my only concern is that it's going to become immensely popular,
which is really a pipe dream.
But if it becomes immensely,
the reason why hockey's still fucking great is because it is sort of the Jan
Brady,
the Middle Kit,
like nobody's fucking paying attention to itself.
You meet the players,
they're all cool.
They're fucking down to earth.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Sorry.
I've even taken a cold medication.
This is just literally my intellect,
so I can't blame anything here.
Um,
but basketball,
I swear to God,
like the Celtics are coming on right,
and the Lakers suck.
And I remember thinking,
as a fan,
this sucks.
We're going to be good and they suck.
It's like if the red sox had gotten the Yankees suck or vice versa,
it's not fun.
Right.
And all of a sudden Lebron is going to move and where does he go to the fucking
Lakers?
And next year there's going to be a bunch of free agents
and the Lakers we'll stock up and I guarantee we're going to go into the finals.
It's going to be fucking Lakers,
Celtics.
You know,
if anybody can get past that juggernaut of,
of um,
of,
uh,
golden state.
But like,
I dunno,
I think it's all,
uh,
it's definitely finessed like a,
like a boxing promoter putting together,
like the fact that they let Kevin Duran go to the Golden State Warriors in the
last two seasons have been an absolute fucking snooze fest.
It's like they,
they knew they were going to win it the second he went there and they did,
you know,
they were going to go back to back and they did.
No.
What they doing and golden state is,
is like what the fuck and Yankees did in the early two thousands and the height
of them buying championships was when they got fucking a road.
Anything Post 1998 cause I love that Yankee team.
I don't want the Yankees,
but I love that team.
But 99,
2000,
the Clemens,
all of that bullshit,
um,
was all those pylon fucking championships.
And then the red sox were like,
well what the fuck?
You know,
we're in the middle of a 90 year drought,
86 year drought here.
This is,
this is the game.
We got to play this game.
And this is the thing,
we haven't stopped playing that fucking game.
I mean,
nobody could be as bad as the fucking Yankees.
remember when they had fucking GMB and a rod in cheater and they're fucking
infield.
It was ridiculous.
They had to have the best shortstops in the league in there,
in filth.
One agreeing to play third base was fucking nuts.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
whatever.
So anyways,
so Lebron is a Laker and uh,
I guess I'm going to get my wish that they're going to be in the finals,
hopefully against us.
I mean,
that's who I want to play and beat.
Um,
and I like our coach better and you know,
I know that they're going to go out and get a zillion guys because everybody in
the NBA wants to play in La.
Not Cause,
you know,
partially because they love the Lakers,
but who doesn't want to fuck a famous broad,
right?
Who doesn't want fucking 75 80 degree weather year round.
I've said this forever.
What do you want to,
do you want to go to Boston Racist Boston and deal with the winter in fucking
sixes and sevens or do you want to come to racist La Bang supermodels and uh,
go to the beach whenever the fuck you want.
12 months of the year,
we can't compete with it.
Made the uniform literally looks like sunshine.
Hey,
speaking of that,
when I was in Minneapolis,
I went by that,
fuck it armory.
I look like an old fucking
like
hockey stadium.
And I would've thought it was the north star old place had I not known that it,
it's where the mall of America is now.
Um,
that wasn't a fucking red flag.
Yeah.
We'll get rid of the hockey team and we're putting the biggest fucking mall
ever.
Um,
I,
I still don't understand how that fucking thing stays open,
you know,
how do you fucking,
you know what the mall of America is like?
It's like having a TV show now.
It's just so many of them.
I would tell you a time,
I was talking to another comedian and I told her how much I liked her show and
she was saying thanks.
And we were talking for five minutes before she realized I was talking about
another show that she had that just got canceled and she was talking about a
different TV show that I didn't even know.
She had two television shows and I had no fucking idea.
Uh,
anyways,
so I went by the armory thing there and I saw Jennifer Lopez blade there during
the Superbowl.
I guess they redid it,
but the coolest fucking thing ever about that venue is that's where the
Minneapolis Lakers with George Mike and when their first four NBA Championships
in that,
uh,
that Baa championship that the Lakers still calling NBA championship,
which is fucking hilarious.
They somehow one one all right before the NBA existed.
But anyways,
I really wanted to go in there and take a fucking tour of it.
So,
uh,
so then we go,
I know a lot of you guys are expecting me to flip out that fucking Lebron went
to.
I don't give a shit.
I like who?
Uh,
I'll thank you.
How are you?
Lovely Nia.
Thumbs up again.
Nothing
you feel run down.
I didn't give it to you today.
I didn't get to get you sick today.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
It's full rundown.
All right,
cool.
Okay,
thanks for taking this morning.
bye.
Uh,
yeah,
my wife was sick too.
You know,
I was also sick,
but you know,
my wife was also kind of sick,
but I was really sick.
So you know what was going to happen,
right?
She's going to sleep in it and I'm going to handle the kit.
That's just how it works.
Tie where you want to keep peace in the house.
That's how it works.
You just fucking,
you baby the shit out of him.
You know.
I would love to say that.
I'll be able to remember that for the next argument so I can be like,
whoa.
What about to fucking time?
I was shook up the nude I to plug in.
What your daughter for the homeless.
I won't remember it.
I don't have that ability.
You know,
you fucking with a woman.
They're like fucking Matlock,
you know,
get fucking start pulling.
I never even watched that show.
You know,
I imagine he was pulling up fucking cases from the past.
I have no idea.
You know what he did last night?
It was on that I couldn't get the fucking sleep.
I was on the Internet there and um,
I was seeing watching all this shit on a Dean Martin and Jerry Lewis.
Just how big and how famous they got everything.
And after they broke up,
uh,
Dean Martin in about 1958 got in the restaurant business and he opened up Dino's
lodge,
which was basically just west of La Sierra go on sunset,
just south.
Now this is giant fucking complex there,
but it's long gone.
I mean they knocked it down to the 80s,
but he got involved in there.
They put his big head there,
Dino's lounge and he went down there and um,
it was a really hip place to go to at first,
late fifties maintains dean and he would actually go down there,
you know,
get the restaurant going,
star struck patrons.
He signed in our graphs and all that shit.
And uh,
do you know,
like fucking two,
three layers of Jerry Lewis opened a competing restaurant down the street.
This is how bad it got.
He opened a competing one and then stole Dean Martin's business partner,
um,
to open that one.
And then he had an even bigger picture of himself on the restaurant and it was
on a pole,
like a hundred feet in the air and it wasn't stationary,
it was revolving.
So I guess dean ended up saying,
hey man,
fuck this shit.
And he got it Coz he's cool.
He said,
fuck this.
He got out of the restaurant business and then he had to sue them to get his
name taken off in the image and he couldn't get it taken off and they,
his face stayed on that restaurant until like the fucking eighties.
Like I said,
when they finally fucking took it out.
But,
um,
anyways,
I just can't imagine that it got that bad,
which of course led me to the 1976 reunion that they had on the Jerry Lewis
Telethon when Jerry had no idea dean was coming out.
Frank brought him out.
Uh,
that was cool watching them.
I'll get all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
It's just stupid fucking falling out stuff.
Um,
but I just thought it was funny at the height,
at the fucking height of them hating each other.
They had competing fucking restaurants.
How not to comedians.
You know,
I just picture,
imagine like De Niro in casino count in the fucking blueberries in the muffin.
Freaking out doing that crazy Jerry Lewis voice saying how dino has more
blueberries in his muffin and this is fucking unacceptable.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
oh,
Billy is a
fucking gonna hang around the house here and get over this shit actually feel a
thousand times better than it felt yesterday.
Um,
I just need to walk around.
They sound weird thing,
you know,
when he gets sick when you're supposed to lay around and relax and you know,
eat,
you know,
is it,
why is it each soup?
You know what I mean?
You slurp it,
right?
This one,
it was hybrid things.
It's almost a gas instead of liquid.
It's not a solid,
you know,
it is a liquid and it's a solid,
that's what it is.
It's like a supergroup of food.
Um,
no,
it is a bill.
It's like cereal.
If you heated it up,
what do you put that?
You know,
they know.
I saw when I was on the road,
I actually saw Pringles potato chips and they had dill flavor and I love fucking
dill pickles and I love Pringles potato chips.
And those two came together and I couldn't get myself to do it because it just,
it was coming across like it was going to be like a supergroup,
you know,
like what if we took fucking Robert Plant and fucking stuck them with Keith
Moon?
Remember they would do shit like that and then it's just,
and then it just never sounded good cause the vibe wasn't there.
I'm just so worried that that's what it's going to be.
You on some level like,
um,
you know,
it's gonna ruin my enjoyment of original Pringles and uh,
and dill pickles.
You are lovable Pringles that they taste delicious and I'm a,
I'm a bit of a neat freak,
although my office is a fucking mess right now.
You know,
I hate fucking dishes in the sink the next morning.
It like depresses me.
I fucking knock him out.
Yeah.
Basically an incredible father and husband is what I'm telling you.
That's my version of it.
That's my version of the story.
Eventually we'll have NIA on here.
What she's feeling better and then she'll probably tell you the truth that I'm a
fucking ass hole over there.
Did Anybody Watch the fucking Austrian,
um,
Formula One race?
That is my favorite fucking Formula One race that I've been,
that I've ever watched and I've only watched since Monaco 2016 and I've missed a
few here or there.
Um,
absolutely loved that fucking race.
I'm a huge fan of Max for,
and I feel like he's the next guy came and Daniel Ricardo,
right?
Daniel Ricardo's gonna fucking leave red bull.
I don't know where he's going to go.
Ferrari.
I don't know if there's room in the Mercedes seem,
I have no fucking idea,
but it was just like the top two guys.
Uh,
what's his face?
Max for stappen and Kimmy Reagan and they're fucking hilarious.
Their press conferences are hilarious.
They're after,
they just,
they don't give a shit.
Um,
you know,
they just,
they have like that comic's comic vibe about him.
Like,
I know when,
um,
I was talking about the last time,
uh,
Sebastian Vettel had banged into a couple of people in Max for staff and during
the,
um,
after the press conference,
he goes,
you guys should tell him he should change his style of driving.
You know,
cause they had said that to him.
And then Tim Max early in the season,
then he goes,
and then fucking Sebastian should continue to drive exactly the way he's driving
cars.
That I haven't changed anything.
And now you guys aren't shitting on him because I'm winning by the way.
And then the United States to hosteen came in fifth and sixth.
That's like our highest place ever was at fourth and fifth or fifth and sixth.
It might've been fourth or fifth.
I got to look it up here.
I can't remember.
But a Mercedes though.
Oh my God,
they had a fucking brutal day.
Abril it SOPs because I wanted,
um,
they always want to see like a close race at the end.
Um,
but I got to be,
I'm a little jaded with this sport where I was just,
you know,
after the first term,
which was,
and it was a fucking incredible start to the race.
MMM.
And I remember when Louis Hamilton,
uh,
got into first place after the first year and I got so over,
he's gonna win.
He's gonna win it.
Put the track was so fucking hot.
That tire started to blister.
Some bullshit happened.
I don't know what and what's his face?
Uh,
no,
we came in fourth and fifth,
corrosion and Magnus in fourth and fifth.
Um,
and lastly,
um,
I don't know what happened.
Somebody was going to fucking slow or something that caused Lewis Hamilton.
They have to slow down and then he got passed and then he had to go into the
fucking pits or say you had to do one extra pitstop is what happened.
And that fucked him.
But that guy is such a good driver.
Even in the end,
the other guy's tires were starting to blister up and he was,
she was just right there and then all the drama went out when he fucking his
car.
Shit,
the bed and I believe,
uh,
Valtteri Botox and some sort of gearbox failure.
But um,
and also what's his face?
Uh,
um,
Daniel Ricardo is please fucking car shit.
The bed too.
He's been having a rough go of it.
But uh,
I just liked it cause it just put different people in the lead that I haven't
seen.
I know Max for has done well over the last few.
Um,
but it was,
it was just fun to watch all of that shit.
Um,
and then watch Louis Hamilton having like the,
the fastest lap of the race trying to catch up like Bill Elliot back in the day
and the stock car races.
And uh,
then unfortunately his car,
shit the bed.
But is the big thing was he was up 14 points.
Lewis Hamilton over a Sebastian Vettel Vettel came in third and I believe you
get 15 points and Lewis Hamilton got no points.
So now ventral is leapfrogged pass him and he's up one point.
Um,
because I was hoping he wasn't going to slowly fucking pull away.
I think they race again next week in Great Britain.
And then they might be on their break,
there's summer break and then there'll be neck and neck for the rest of the
year.
So far Ferrari can fucking hang in there.
It should be exciting,
right through a Brazil and on into November where they,
what are they always end up,
he said Dubai,
he can't fucking remember.
Um,
so anyways,
very fucking excited about that race.
Uh,
maybe I sucked.
You know that Mercedes got knocked down is also Daniel Ricardo.
But it was just fun to see some new blood up there and then,
you know,
watching Louis Hamilton putting on a fucking show as he was dealing with the
foot,
his tires literally falling apart.
Um,
anyways,
when I was,
uh,
when I was in also when I was in,
Minneapolis,
if forgot to tell you I was going to try a different place to get a juicy Lucy.
Last time I went to maths bar and I got this fucking Uber driver.
It's hilarious.
This Indian guy
and there's a lot of construction going on downtown in Minneapolis and it said
he was five minutes away for 15 minutes.
He finally pulls up and this dude was like the fucking old Indian version of me.
Like he was like snapping on me cause he was mad about construction.
But I understood it because like it took me a minute to figure out like,
why is this guy yelling at me?
I go,
I want to go to whatever that fucker was.
The five [inaudible] club was going to try that one next,
right?
And he goes,
I need an address medially yelling at me.
And I go,
all right dude,
relax.
No,
you can't just say the name of that place.
I need an address.
I was like to stop yelling at me.
He goes,
I'm not yelling at you,
aren't you?
Yes.
You argue,
yell at.
And then verse,
he gets in the car,
he's looking at me,
I'm like,
dude,
this guy's fucking nut.
You know,
this guy's yelling at me.
And he goes,
I need an address.
And I'm like,
well,
the name of the places is,
is the five eight club putting your phone,
you fucking cunt.
Right?
So now I went to his energy,
but fortunately I've been really working on it and I brought it back down again
and I was just like,
hey,
all right.
You know?
Okay,
like I understand this traffic here,
right?
Let's,
and then he was trying to smile his way through it,
realize that he went to fucking nuts.
So I think I gave the wrong address.
He would have taken us to Matt Bar.
So now it's like really tense,
Barb.
Nick's riding in the front seat and this fucking guy's little,
it's like we're with our fucking angry grandfather who are all trying to be on
our best behavior.
So Barton x tries to lighten the mood.
We see this fat chick on a bicycle,
you know,
she was at a dead stop and that she's trying to get it going.
So it's just like,
you know,
it's precarious when you start off a bike,
if you're not pedaling fast enough,
especially when you carrying that kind of weight and Barney was a Jesus Christ.
Look at her man.
He goes,
they don't have assets like that in India,
do they?
He's like,
maybe on an elephant.
Right.
And the guy started laughing.
I was just like,
yeah,
that'd be a fucking sacred cow over there.
And we just fucking broke the ice.
We broke the ice by making fun of a fat chick and bringing up stereotypical shit
from that guy's culture.
That's how we did it.
And then he pulled up,
he ended up pulling up to Matt's bar instead of the five,
eight club.
And I was like,
oh,
this isn't where I wanted to go.
And he kind of looked at me.
I was just like,
forget it.
It's all right.
It's fine.
I just,
I don't wanna get yelled at again.
I was living like a battered wife at that point.
Like,
okay,
Bye Dad.
I love you.
Is fucking drove off.
Um,
all right,
let me read,
let me read a little bit of a,
and by the way,
it was delicious.
And they,
they have,
uh,
they get mail a half Miller high life and a bottle there.
You know,
they want the dangerous thing about a Miller high life.
Is this just something about the bottle?
It feels like it's eight ounces.
It just doesn't feel like it's 12 ounces of beer and they just,
they just go down so easy,
you know?
And I had a show that night,
so,
uh,
you know,
ended up having a think we had like two and the waitress was cool,
she was asking us about the show.
We ended up hooking her up and then she gave us some fucking hats and shit,
man,
I was really just,
it was fucking up in Minneapolis is,
it's fucking awesome.
The people up there are fucking awesome.
And then I go to Detroit,
you know,
the fucking great.
And I actually was actually like,
as I just literally landed,
went to the hotel and then went out and did the show.
So let's do my typical Detroit material,
but are white people,
you know,
drive a hundred miles an hour into,
uh,
the tiger's game and after that,
you know,
and then drive back out,
cause it's so fucked up in the downtown area.
And I knew it was making a comeback.
Every time I go there,
it's a little bit nicer.
But dude,
it's like those jokes are over now.
I walked out after my show at about 10 30 at night and I saw a white guy,
a white kid on a bicycle with a backpack riding down the street,
not even nervous.
And I was just like,
like,
it's,
it's in a real estate sense,
it's too late to buy there.
You're already going to be paying like fucking top shelf prices.
If the neighborhood got to the point where a white guy will ride down the street
late at night,
you know,
with a backpack on,
he wasn't like a fucking,
you know,
he wasn't like eight mile m and m white guy.
He was a white guy like me,
you know,
a suburban,
a suburban night,
a non dancing suburban white kid.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
they had like a John Varvatos downtown.
It was fucking ridiculous.
I remember years ago I was telling versus going through it,
I'm going to buy some property here.
This place is gonna fucking blow up because you're out of your mind.
I was just like too,
it's a notebook.
It's here.
It's just what I saw this happen in Pittsburgh.
I saw this happen in Cleveland.
I just didn't have fucking money at the time was I was fucking put it in this
Goddamn,
you know,
fucking money pit of a house that I bought.
It's a nice house now.
It's a nice house now,
but I,
this is literally body off restoration.
He had to do this fucking house.
Sorry.
Anyways,
uh,
and I remember seeing on the Anthony Bourdain show,
parts unknown,
rest his soul.
I saw a guy,
he bought a skyscraper there for 5 million bucks and I was thinking there was
any way you could scrape together 5 million bucks and then renovate it,
which I don't know what that would cost another 50,
45.
And if you could just sit on that,
I mean,
there's still a way that it's a skyscraper that city makes a comeback.
That thing,
you know,
say is 60 billion in it,
it's gonna be worth a quarter of $1 billion.
And you know who fucking did all that shit.
The,
uh,
the owner of the Cleveland Cavaliers,
he went down there,
he bought a bunch of fucking buildings,
redid them,
had made the office a space cheap and he filled them up with these internet
companies and um,
made me feel good.
Then I was going to make the same moves at a billionaire fucking owner of a
basketball team was going to make,
I just didn't down the fucking money.
Um,
anyways,
but,
uh,
I'm very,
very happy for that city as I was for Cleveland as I am for Pittsburgh and all
that shit because it's such great cities,
Buffalo,
Baltimore,
all of those cities going right through the Dayton.
I love all of those fucking cities and they,
and all they need is just people to fucking invest in them.
You know what I mean?
I'll tell you when we're done free in the Iraqis,
we ought to come back here and try to help out some of these fucking cities.
Get him going against our building.
Shit.
You know,
if I was running shit,
I'd have these fucking hipsters,
right?
I would just have them like,
what are you into right now?
What are you going to bring back from the past and do it in some artists in
fucking way and you know,
just,
you know,
give him a break on factories and shit and just start making stuff here again.
You'll say what you want about hipsters.
They like a lot of cool stuff there.
Just insufferable to talk to.
Um,
all right.
The black box both.
Sorry,
the Black Tux.
I don't know if that was from watching too much porn or having a pilot's
license.
The Black Tux,
a wedding season is upon us.
Uh,
you're going to be doing it big and going out to all your buddies weddings.
When you bringing a date,
you want to look fresh.
Yeah.
You want to hook up.
You don't have to bring a date.
You want to go there like fucking Jim Carrey.
Dumb and dumber,
but have a cool Tuxedo.
But it has to be convenient.
That's where the black,
the black Tux comes in.
The black tops has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles and your
rent them online.
All right.
I just hit pause and I blew my nose while it wasn't recording.
See,
I learned from my mistakes.
The black Tux offers the kind of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally be
wildly expensive to buy,
and you might only wear it once like the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo.
It's Funky,
it's cool.
But how many times you gonna to wear an Emerald Green Tuxedo with the Black Tux?
You can,
yeah,
you can do you and blow it out for your big event.
One,
one time event.
Yeah,
you gotta,
you gotta go with something a little bit flashy and don't bring a fucking date
automatically before you even open your mouth.
You're going to seem interesting.
Forget about when the ladies start drinking.
Next thing you know,
you're out there doing the mock arena,
right?
And you're like,
why would you ever get married?
And that's called being in your 20s all right,
so try out a new look.
Do something different and takes your style to the next level.
With the Black Tux free home.
Try on.
You can see the fit and feel the quality of your suits month per month before
the event.
It's a hard word to say,
plural
months.
I've been doing that for fucking months,
I think I say months.
Mun s months.
Munc after ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a replacement right away and remember how simple
returns are where it turn heads and then send it back three days after your
event.
Shipping is free both ways.
Standout at your event for the right reason with the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase,
visit the Black tux.com/bird that's the black tux.com/bar for $20 off your
purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos.
All right,
here we go.
Lastly,
but certainly not leastly simply safe.
Here's what I love about simply safe.
These guys obsess over details.
It's why the alarm system is so good.
Here's an example.
A typical glass break.
Sensors sometimes gets fooled of false positive sounds like dropping plates,
a baby crying.
Oh,
then it freaks out.
He says,
British are coming or the sky's falling.
Simply saved in,
want to settle for a typical,
didn't want to set a for typical because really good home security should be
really accurate.
So they actually considered a glass break test facility.
Yeah.
Well they have a bunch of toddlers in there throwing glasses.
They ran over 10,000 live glass breaks,
simulations,
refining their technology,
the detection technology,
until it was so accurate.
It continues.
It can distinguish a broken plate from a broken window.
Jesus Christ.
Can you believe somebody knows to like make up fucking a little piece of
electronics?
Understand that.
Yeah.
Even if they go not relevant,
you're going to be in 10 years.
This is the level of details.
Simply safe puts into everything they do.
It sets them apart from other security companies.
Simply safe system is designed so you will never notice it.
Never have to think about it.
It's that easy and intuitive.
There is no contract.
They work hard to earn your business.
24,
seven monitoring with police and fire dispatch.
It's just $15 a month.
It's the best around the cloud protection you can find.
Protect your home today.
Visit simply safe bird.com now,
that's simply safer.com simply safer.com.
Um,
yeah,
but think why the people at the top are not concerned about the environment
generally speaking and how they're content to just fucking use up all the oil,
kill as many people as they need to kill to get the fucking oil,
you know,
pollute the air as much as they can throw it in the fucking rivers.
Why they don't give a shit?
You know,
how was just thinking?
I think it's because we're all going,
you know,
all us regular people are going to get replaced by robots.
You know what I mean?
The liberal Black Comedians,
you know,
robot fucking whores,
whatever the hell you want it,
you know,
I don't know.
Kind of ran out of jobs there,
but you know what I mean.
And then they're still gonna,
they're still gonna live and they're going to be that upper 1% and they're going
to have like,
just like essentially,
uh,
an entire population that never complains is totally into what the fuck they're
doing.
I think they'll keep,
uh,
a group of people,
human beings as slaves and their job will be to fuck and make more people so
that these older fucking rich one percenters can harvest their organs and live
forever.
That's what I think.
Those are the kinds of things that I think when I'm alone,
um,
have you got to figure the first time you kill somebody for the,
your Oregon's,
you could just going to do that forever.
Cause it's like,
well I don't if there's a higher power,
I don't think I want them meet him or her with,
with that on the resume,
you know,
God just sitting across to you,
well you were busy
sitting there,
shifted in that fucking chair.
You just fucking know exactly what the fuck he's do.
You know exactly what he's talking about.
Like,
that one's going to pop up and you got everybody's got probably that one thing
except for truly good people,
which I'm not,
you know.
Okay.
That can fire,
you know when I die,
if there is an afterlife,
I feel like God's gonna like fucks with you.
Like you sit across the room and he just looks down at your,
your resume,
right.
Probably has like the half glasses,
you know,
sitting on the end of his fucking all mighty knows eyebrows up and shit.
And then he just kinda looks across the is probably like a,
do you want me to,
you want,
you want to tell me about this?
You know,
and then you're sitting there going,
oh,
what's he talking about?
Is this a trick?
Uh,
Oh shit.
He can hear what I'm thinking.
Don't think about all the shit you did,
Bill.
He's going to know
it's gonna be such a mind fuck.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
I don't know.
That's a weird fucking topic.
Dying.
Uh,
well the fuck around my,
but the hills,
all my shit.
Oh,
there it is.
Was trying to find on like my fucking shit.
I wanted to talk about,
okay.
Detroit's fucking gorgeous white dude on a bicycle.
Too late to invest.
See,
that's what I do.
I just read a couple of words.
Oh yeah,
that's what I wanted to talk about.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm so psyched to be back out here in Los Angeles.
You know,
when I was in Detroit,
um,
it's weird when I was in Minneapolis,
I already what they were known for,
which is the juicy Lucy,
which is a fucking incredible,
like the one it maths bar.
They've got this nice char on it.
Then they got the cheese of course in the middle and it's molten hot,
so you gotta be careful,
nibble,
nibble around the outside.
And um,
so it was,
it was delicious.
And,
um,
and the beer was ice cold.
It was fucking great.
It made me wish I didn't have a show that night.
I was like,
I think I want another one of these and I want to sit here and just fucking
watch a game,
you know?
And,
um,
but then I went to Detroit
and,
um,
you know,
I ordered Tacos,
stupid fucking move.
I mean they were good,
but they weren't,
but you know,
they're not.
La La knows is known for Tacos.
San Francisco is known for Burritos
and I'm known for being pasty.
Oh,
let's talk a world cup.
Shall We?
Let's see what's going on in the FIFA World Cup.
I watched a couple of games.
Um,
I can't even tell you who the fuck I saw.
I did see the highlights.
So when I wanted to watch was Brazil and Mexico,
you know what I mean?
I mean that was just a fucking soccer supernova as far as I was concerned about
Russia beaten Spain,
that,
that was like the fucking lake placid moment,
you know.
And I was sitting at immediately going like,
oh this is going to be weird.
It's Russia keeps moving along.
You know,
you watch America is going to be a bunch of babies about it,
you know,
cause everybody's already saying that they kind of fucked with our election or
whatever.
And uh,
you know,
of course the election now,
the World Cup,
they don't like we give a shit.
Um,
but game did I watch,
I watched the Dutch people play?
Uh,
uh,
fuck,
I can't remember.
But the other people want some of the best goaltending I've seen in soccer ever.
The fucking game starts,
first of all,
uh,
the Dutch guys,
right?
Oh,
is it Denmark?
Denmark,
right.
They fucking a a Denmark Dutch people.
Is that the Netherlands?
I don't know.
I'm an American.
They don't talk about the rest of the world.
Okay.
They talk about the fucking white people that started this country.
That's what gets driven into your fucking skull.
MMM.
So the,
uh,
Denmark,
she scores a goal like 40 seconds in or a minute in or something like that.
And then like 45 seconds later,
the other guy score the guys who won.
Yeah.
I can't fucking remember Croatia.
So luckiest Sylvania,
Romania.
MMM.
I don't know who the fuck it was.
They fucking score.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this is finally my dream game.
Ben and a half.
And there's already been two goals.
This is some shit American can appreciate.
And then there wasn't another goal for like another fucking hour and a half.
But,
uh,
I do have to say the goaltending was fucking incredible.
All right.
And that guy with his fucking golden fucking locks there,
go come head for fucking
in Denmark was incredible.
And then the other guy was just a fucking lunatic.
One of those guys,
you could tell he can't shut it off after the game and they would just guess it,
right?
Uh,
they dive and then the guy would shoot to the middle of the fucking get his foot
out while he was diving the other way.
Uh,
and whenever you miss a penalty fucking kick like is,
is the shooter,
whatever you fuck,
you call them,
right?
They,
you know that they're fucking,
they're just thinking like,
Oh God,
I'm going to get fucking,
I'm never going to hear the end of this when I go back to my country.
I'm never going to hear the fucking end of this,
you know,
unless somebody steps up and saves my fucking ass.
So I did see that game.
I did see the Brazil game with that Rinaldo guy.
Oh my God.
I thought for half a second he was literally on fire.
You know,
like when will Ferrell was running around and Ricky Bobby with the invisible
flames,
he was tearing off all his clothes.
I thought that that's who it was.
What was happening.
Um,
I mean,
I know the guys,
it definitely should have been a penalty.
It was a piece of shit move.
The guy stepped on him.
He raked is fucking cleat right across his ankle.
I imagine it's smarted but Jesus Christ that was like silent film acting.
MMM.
Depending wins against Brazil.
One,
two to nothing.
And uh,
we're getting down to it.
So I imagine France or England was playing today,
right?
No,
France is going to play.
They were already in like a,
they're already in.
Why don't I look it up?
FIFA World Cup standings and then you've got to fight through all these CBS cars
that don't fucking have it.
I want the grid and what the bracket,
give me the bracket.
World Cup bracket,
CBS sports.
You're gonna fuck me against CBS sports.
Come on
slowly opening.
This fucking website sucks.
It keeps saying brackets.
It doesn't have the bracket.
Whereas our bracket,
there's nothing I can,
I can click on schedule.
The standings are,
who the fuck's play in today?
World Cup schedule.
I'm clicking.
No,
you fucking asshole.
Russia 2018 schedule.
Oh my God.
I found the bracket.
All right.
Oh,
I watched the Erg way.
Always.
I was Uruguay.
Earl grey,
beat Portugal.
I watched that game shot up.
I watched uh,
Croatia be dead.
MMM.
I guess Sweden beat Switzerland for the love of,
I don't know why.
The abbreviation for their country is Sui.
There's no you in Switzerland.
Why would it be WWE?
Is that too close to Sweden?
MMM.
Brazil is clean.
Belgium.
All right,
so the last person who has to get in is,
is England,
is playing Columbia.
When the fuck is that game,
I got to take that one.
Then they get into the quarter finals,
then there's the semis,
and then there's a final game.
Fucking goes by so fast.
So it was one,
two,
this three,
basically three more rounds.
MMM.
And I'm going to watch it for once.
I don't think I've watched the final since that guy from Italy missed that
penalty shot.
You know,
but I,
I remember when I was a kid way back in the 80s,
Diego,
Donna,
the hand of God and all of that Shit.
But,
uh,
other than that I remember also was in the,
it wasn't it in the u s and like 94 and like 30 Americans showed up,
but it's still sold out because everybody around the world was like so excited.
Like,
oh my God,
it's going to be so easy to get tickets.
Let's go.
MMM.
All right,
let's read some,
uh,
some of the fucking questions here for the week.
Was it really,
really need to swear right there.
All right.
Um,
where are we?
Sweden.
Oh,
speaking of that,
please come to Sweden.
Last time you were here,
I was a little kid and it didn't know about you,
but I really liked your podcasts and your stand up is amazing,
isn't it?
Like how young that person is.
I haven't been there about five years,
you know?
So what have you,
like 15?
You'd probably still already like five,
11 super tall kids of,
I'm putting together an eastern European tour,
by the way.
Um,
hopefully for the beginning part of next year.
I'm teasing that,
that that's what's going to be happening when we go into a bunch of countries
that I've never been to before.
And uh,
but I know I have to get back to Sweden.
I haven't been there and way too way too long,
so I will definitely get back there.
All right.
Uh,
thank you for the compliments of my podcast and my stand up.
can a comic cover a comedic bit like a musician?
Uh,
no they can't.
They can't.
Let's he tells everybody,
remember that Cosby bit?
You remember that prior bit dear bill one ran away from an aneurysm birth of I
hit how true that is,
Ken.
I want to be stand up Co.
Oh,
want to be state.
You're not an actual standup comedian.
Cover comedic bit like a wannabe musician would cover his son.
I'm not talking about a paid gig.
Just an open Mike.
Nah,
don't do that because you're already,
you're,
even though you're not a pro,
cause you're not getting paid.
You are.
Yeah.
You don't do that.
This is,
there's no coffee house of standup comedy set.
If you're a professional like yourself and I'm putting on a special,
it should be totally original content.
Um,
the thing is not all of us are as funny as you,
but we still want to make the world laugh and get a taste of the spotlight and
maybe some groupie pussy to it.
If you think that you're going to go up on an open mic,
I don't give a fuck if you kill with original material.
When you get off stage,
you still have to have game.
That's the thing about being a comedian as a fucking musician.
You go up there and you start singing a song,
it's fucking over.
I mean,
you,
you can do that at a fucking coffee house singing other people's fucking songs
and it's just going to be rain in fucking vagina.
Uh,
comedians,
we can go up there for an hour,
hour and a half with their own material and you still have to work for it.
You know,
they want you to still be funny when you get off stage.
Keep being funny keeping.
They don't want the other guy to fucking sing.
He can sit there brooding,
you know,
smoking his cigarette.
Um,
anyways.
Now your initial response will probably be something along the lines.
No,
go write your own material.
You lazy piece of Shit.
Uh,
you call me illiterate.
At least I can write my own jokes.
Oh,
you trying out material right now?
I did my time in the nightclubs bombing on stage and as a young,
skinny redhead.
And you don't think I just wanted to go out there,
blah,
blah.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You leave these lazy cut.
Uh,
the thing is I don't strive to be a professional comedian as,
as engineering pays a lot better.
And writing my own jokes seems like too much work too.
I really don't give a shit about you right now.
You know what I mean?
Hey Man,
like I,
you know,
I mean I just want to go fucking a play once,
one down of professional football without getting hit.
Yeah,
go fuck yourself.
Uh,
I just want to go on stage and give the illusion that I'm funny.
So maybe a girl will think,
I actually have a personality.
You want to fuck me?
Oh,
now we're getting to it.
Now we're getting to it.
All right,
so you're an engineer.
You probably introverted,
you're super smart,
but you don't have anything going on with the ladies.
So right now you think in like,
so you'll,
oh,
that's funny.
And then you think that funny guys that comedians get a ton of ass.
Uh,
I'm not saying there are guys out there that do,
but they work.
It's fucking,
or unless you know,
you'd fucking ridiculously good looking,
but like it's fucking work.
Um,
if it is out,
know if you're extended comedian,
you kind of have like that slumber vibe,
slumber party vibe,
energy,
like all my God,
you got guys,
it's weird.
It's like a feminine,
you know,
if you almost,
it's just a weird thing about women.
If you give off an a feminine energy,
you're actually going to get more fucking ass than a fucking,
uh,
a guy
or I guess a guy vibe.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
look at David Bowie.
The Guy was walking around wearing dresses.
There was just women with prince was wearing high heel shoes,
his whole fucking,
they eat,
they,
it was like a,
like the locusts,
except it was all vaginas flying at those guys.
So maybe that's what you need to to do rather than,
uh,
rather than steel from comedians.
I would steal from Prince and David Bowie and I would think that you guys are
all down there.
Everybody's wearing like the fucking white lab coat.
If you added a little bit of Flair of feminine flare to your scientific is
scientists coat,
who knows,
go to work,
design a bridge while wearing some fucking prince high yields.
Fucking boots are telling you you're,
you're automatically,
you're going to be fucking interesting.
All right,
let me keep reading here.
Uh,
I just want to go and save Blah,
blah,
blah.
He goes,
I look at it like it's a scientific report.
It's not plagiarism as long as you cite where you got the information from.
So if at the beginning of the set I said something like most essays I wrote in
college,
this set is completely plagiarized.
That's a funny joke to sir.
Consisting of ideas from people much smarter than me.
And the only original thing I have to say is this opening line in some assets
somewhere else has probably already said this too.
Or at the end of the set I say,
thanks for listening.
If you want to see those jokes,
they're actually supposed to be performed.
How those jokes were actually supposed to be four and go check out bill barr.
Dude,
you're cutting yourself short.
You're actually a funny guy.
You're just lazy.
Um,
you could actually use that opener and then go into one of the oldest jokes of
all time,
you know,
one of those fucking war environments where red suspenders and be like,
I'm just fucking with you.
And then to just talk about being a fucking engineer and I get no game with
women.
You only have to be up there for five minutes.
All right?
To that,
I actually think you want to fucking do this.
And I also think you funny from that first line.
All right,
so there's,
there's a year two options.
All right?
If,
if,
yeah.
Sincerely from an unoriginal fan from the great white north.
You're funny,
you're self deprecating.
You got enough here that it,
it's not crazy to me that,
that you would go up and do an open mic,
but uh,
you know,
it's the laziness factor that you just want to go up there and do other people's
Shit.
But I understand.
I remember the first time I sat down to write like,
okay,
I'm going to write jokes.
It's the weirdest feeling ever.
It's like,
how do you do this?
Like what do I even fucking,
what am I going to talk about?
How do I connect one idea to another?
You're not supposed to know.
All right?
So just open with that line.
Talk about your life.
You know,
who gives a fuck if you bail after three minutes?
That's what I did.
I didn't even get through the five minutes.
They look at me,
tell her Dick Jokes all across the lead.
All right?
But um,
you're not going to get respect from other comics,
other open mikes going out there and do it other people's fucking material and
you will immediately be branded a thief.
Watch out for this guy and there'll be a bunch of open makers who were severely
insecure and they're going to need a target to fucking focus.
They're awful childhoods on and that's going to be you.
So I would open with that joke.
I would close with what the fuck he said.
I wouldn't do other people's material.
I talk about my life.
And when you're at work,
you know,
whatever,
put a bow on assumption,
tried to be interesting.
And a bank,
one of the egg egg chicks she fucking work with.
You know,
you guys can't go see star wars or something.
I Dunno.
Good luck to Ya.
All right everybody,
I'll check it on your,
on our Thursday.
I'll,
uh,
have a great couple of days.
You fucking suck.
Let's go.
Fuck yourselves.